tout commence le 29 novembre 1932 dans
le 5e arrondissement de paris à la
clinique de la rue geoffroy
saint-hilaire où jacques chirac vient au
monde
pourtant ses origines familiales nous
emmène en corrèze dans le village de
sainte féréole où il décroche son tout
premier mandat de conseiller municipal
en 1965
en 1969 il achète avec sa femme
bernadette le château de bity dans la
ville de sarran où ils sont tous les
deux élus
[Musique]
mais c'est bien à paris que se joue
l'essentiel de la carrière politique de
jacques chirac
[Musique]
tout d'abord au numéro 123 de la rue de
lille dans le 7e arrondissement au siège
du rpr et bien plus tard au numéro 119
de cette même rue qui hébergera ses
bureaux ou après son départ de l'elysée
il se rendra à chaque matin sa carrière
se poursuit dans un lieu emblématique de
la capitale
l'hôtel de ville il utilise comme un
tremplin pour accéder à la présidence
il y siège de 1977 à 1995
de son passage au ministère de
l'agriculture ils gardent
particulièrement le plaisir de se rendre
au salon de l'agriculture où tous les
ans ils goûtent les produits du terroir
français et sert des milliers de mains
en ce qui concerne le reste du monde
le japon est depuis toujours une
destination privilégiée il s'y est rendu
plus d'une quarantaine de fois
et l'ancien président ne manque jamais
d'assister à un combat de sumos qu'il
affectionne particulièrement
[Musique]
très jeune il s'était rendu aux états
unis à la nouvelle-orléans y avait écrit
un mémoire et apprécier les clubs de
jazz et la cuisine créole ne manqueront
pas d'évoquer son amitié avec le roi
hassan ii et son fils le roi du maroc
mohamed 6 qui font de ce pays un lieu de
villégiature régulier été comme hiver
bien sûr la côte d'azur et plus
précisément la côte varoise et le fort
de brégançon
mais aussi bormes les mimosas et saint
tropez sont pour l'ancien président des
lieux qu'il apprécie pour y passer ses
vacances